oh my gosh first of all I've got to give
you guys major props because you must be
the nicest cast at comic-con who passed
out donuts to the fans like some people
were like waking up you know so great is
that the show has finally premiered last
year when we're talking to you guys
didn't know anything you guys are so
good about staying tight-lipped about
the show what has the fan reaction been
like for you now that I've been seeing
the show it's overwhelming yeah and it's
really fun to see people cosplaying as
our characters that they didn't know
last year just the embrace we really
feel in briefs we feel welcomed into the
fold it's it's amazing there was a lot
of excitement last year which we were so
grateful for and it was excitement of
what's to come and now it's excitement
of what has come which is really I don't
know it's really it's really comforting
it's really encouraging you know we love
it you're kind of doing it in a vacuum
you're not quite sure you know what the
reactions gonna be and you're hoping and
praying that people will love what
you're doing is you're putting your
whole heart and soul into it but to have
the response that we did receive has
been overwhelming and you know people
warned you about this fandom they're
like be prepared I was not I thought I
was prepared
as fans we were not prepared to see a
very important new element introduced in
the season 1 finale when we got a
distress call from the USS oh can we
talk a little bit about the introduction
of that who was totally geeking out when
you read that in the script I didn't
even know about it
because I wasn't in that episode I
watched it along with everybody else and
when that ship literally jumped out of
my dad was like well how does the
introduction of the USS Enterprise such
an iconic Star Trek spaceship affect
season 2 it's pretty significant I mean
obviously Captain Pike you should have
shown up from the enterprise and he's
here for a very specific reason yeah but
what what we will discover is that the
reason that the enterprise is here is
tied into a larger story that is really
the thrust of season 2 that isn't about
the enterprise I'm going to try and get
something spoilers I think we've heard
that we could be getting maybe
flashbacks to younger Spock who of
course is is foster sister of Michael is
there any way that we might be able to
see us get back to you we haven't
thought about it
what can fans expect from season two
it's like a settling from the the
craziness of the war you know there's a
there's the aftermath of everybody being
able to take time and space no pun
intended to take stock and to reconnect
and heal yeah so there's a lot of that a
lot of a lot of great scenes
conversations between characters things
that were really really percolating in
season one and yeah exactly you're
getting to kind of see the inside of
everyone's mind in any way questions of
faith and every way that work can be
applied yes which is incredible and then
something that Alex was saying earlier
about the family dynamic it's not just
about you know the the family that
people are asking about but it's also
that you know we're exploring what we
are as a family and and what it really
means to be family and you know and that
will be tested many times
hopefully in season two we also get a
more streamlined makeup process for you
done actually it's down down yeah it's
less than two hours now I make our
makeup artists earn Amin Amin
[Applause]
and we are so excited for season 2 what
is the one thing you want to say they're
fans right now who are watching who just
cannot wait until 2019 thank you thank
you for sticking with us yes and we're
excited for you guys that guys we're
excited about how excited they're gonna
be about what yeah yeah we give our all
and we appreciate that they give their
all to well I appreciate you guys
stopping by today thank you so much for
watching right now keep it off to EG
live because we're gonna be bringing you
exclusive interviews from comic-con bye
guys
[Music]
[Music]